[Music]
in Seoul only news ronery oh yeah or
that one
yeah from tumor submitted by non-flat TV
mount flash CRT so like all boxy guys
that's what they were called yeah sure
projection one mm-hmm
yeah rear lip projection yeah dude I
will say it's way easier to play and 64
on those TVs because they have the
cables oh yeah gotta get converters for
that what we do it we do this is a lot
trouble for us gotcha I missed those TVs
with the VCRs attached oh yeah still in
the VCR
yeah the VCR on my TV it could come it
came with its own VCR thing and I would
hide stuff in there like pot what that's
genius why didn't I think of that birth
control when I started having sex my mom
didn't know or that's like the first
place a cop would look you know where I
had my [ __ ] in my [ __ ] Walmart desk
you could take a knife pop out to one of
the ends and then there's another
plastic piece you have to pop back and
then there was a whole empty see Walmart
why don't you sponsor David yeah okay
here we go
here are five surprising truths about
loneliness why does this sound like a
BuzzFeed video hey my people this is a
BuzzFeed
no the BBC it's another BBC big black
cup yeah so there are 55,000 people that
took part in BBC's lonliness experiment
didn't have a problem finding people for
that huh so it's like the largest survey
of its kind fifty-five thousand is a lot
55,000 people yeah so what they found
out is number one younger people feel
lonelier than older people this weather
you're trying to figure [ __ ] out
all the people don't be mom but I think
as younger people rely on the energy of
others and the older people are [ __ ]
tired of other people yes exactly
because like you're young you're in
school like most of your life and all
sudden you get dumped out into the world
and you're like oh [ __ ] yeah that's
exactly what they're mentioned too it's
like when you're younger too so that
this age group is 16 to 24 they're the
loneliest people that took this survey
here and they're saying that that's
because when you're young you're still
trying to figure out like your own
feelings and then like what you're
saying it's like then you start being
out on your own or like there's emo
phase like you don't go to school
anymore or you like you change schools
and the people you grew up with you no
longer see them all the time so fact one
not surprising yeah because you're not
always these are supposed to be
surprising truth not old enough that
drinking sighs so it is surprising like
the general public I wasn't surprised
eight you're not part of the general
okay she's like secretly no no wait
so like the reason why it's surprising
is because a lot of people think that
the oldest people in this category in
the survey that they would be the
loneliest I would have agreed with that
cuz like senior citizens that are like
in-home stuff yes or exactly that's why
people with seniors would have the most
fun because it's like going back to
college again with like you're in the
dormitory or a lot of your friends are
free to chill cuz everyone's retired and
[ __ ] so you go on these cruises but you
look you like don't your limited
mobility though all I know is that I
just want to die before burial that's
right I can't I can't
meeps know I got a guy before that [ __ ]
dude oh all are you die i'ma stay alive
no [ __ ] that because when people ask me
like you know like like like in the
future when people go oh how was TIFF
like I never got to meet her and I'm I
could talk as much [ __ ] as I'll LA
because she's deaf yeah just like defend
yourself they're like a brain hooked up
to an AI everyone's like ooh tell me
what it was like behind the scenes on JK
news and I'm gonna I'll tell you all the
[ __ ] details and everyone won't
believe the [ __ ] out
everyone in that generation 80 years
from now knows JK news and nobody has to
be dead for that the right know behind
the scene but they see behind us he's on
the vlog blog no it's gonna be the
commenters that that are gala with it
was it real when you guys were sitting
next to each other you guys were [ __ ]
and all that stuff cuz I want to know
they've been holding I'm gonna be like
oh yeah they were going through some
problems yeah yeah it has to be like
saved up Saved by the Bell if your
screech you got to sell the [ __ ] book
right if you're Dustin Diamond you got
to sell that [ __ ] book so you got
like yo everyone's [ __ ] everyone's
doing drugs you a present for like
killing someone yeah for staffing I got
like stabbing someone yeah screech yeah
he has a dildo made from his dick it's
just one of those fun facts you hear
yeah we did an article that's how I
found out it was on Jay King his media
proves he's like that guy got that from
your source number two 41% of people
think loneliness can be positive
wait I think there's a difference
between lonely and being alone so the
way that they're so the majority of
people who define loneliness so these
are the five things people say
loneliness is having nobody to talk to
[Laughter]
feeling disconnected from the world
feeling left out
sadness and not feeling understood me
too what for other reasons I can't talk
I have people to talk to but like all
the rest I feel but I could I feel like
you could feel lonely it's all about
what's inside like you could feel lonely
in a crowd of people you could feel
lonely at a party Tokyo is a great place
to be lonely at because it accommodates
for loneliness long yeah like you can
eat alone you could try like a do a lot
of [ __ ] and you don't feel alone cuz
there's so many [ __ ] people there all
yeah and then but then you also feel
like that you'll get that anxiety when
you eat or whatever that you're by
yourself in this open space because they
have these [ __ ] cubicles and every
thing feels like I've never made and my
life felt more lonely than when me and
Nikki went to a house party filled with
like nineteen year old girl oh my god
yeah we were like two old different
language yeah and like we didn't know
anybody except for the birthday we were
invited by a fellow thirty year old
person yeah but then we got there we
discovered that it was filled with
nineteen year old all their friends know
I was invited by a 20 year old person no
yeah yeah but like I was invited by the
20 year old oh I didn't I start coke
chameleon izing myself like we were in
playlist in Florida like you guys are
like all these kids and I'm like yeah
and I was like [ __ ] dude I think I'm
starting to blend and like I'm melting
I'm like I'm melting I'm like that uncle
that still thinks he's young I think
that's what I'm gonna be actually yeah
what's up friends and they're all like
these are coming what's the house kids
yeah [ __ ] it is [ __ ] you know what
people told me when I moved here what
that la is like the loneliest city I
heard that too oh yeah why only I've
never had more friends in my life no I
think this is the perception of people
always putting on a front so you don't
really get to know people you get to
know that persona you know who told you
that a loser locals or transplants
that's what I'm saying is like most
locals don't it's a [ __ ] different
world right like most people that come
here they come here for entertainment
they come here to live in the big city I
come here because they may have this ego
and then he gets put in check yes and
then they're like oh [ __ ] I feel lonely
just were friends though
and the first year was pretty lonely
here well it's hard because everyone
groups though it's cuz like oh you got
like the people in the east side the
Culver City side you know this the
valley side but and then BuzzFeed you're
like we got the list people food people
you know I mean we got BuzzFeed sports
whatever that is well I mean you you
moved down here from Sacre you're pretty
much transplant but you made friends
like that cuz you can filter through
shitty people yeah well I'm a very
sociable person but I I don't have I
have a lot of acquaintances but I have a
very small amount of friends so it's
like for me it's like if I find people I
like I usually stick with them so I met
these dudes and that was it five years
later you know and so you know and a lot
of people too like usually I click with
it if I do it works well if not I'm good
at smiling in front of you and I won't
be rude to you yeah but don't be mad if
I don't call you up you know what it is
though it's because I'm coming I'm not
saying I'll people to Ohio like this but
I came from a place where you could
trust everybody yeah
is that a small town or it was in a
smaller town yeah and then but then
they're like nothing in the game from
each other but then you moved here or I
moved here and it was like I didn't have
a BS meter so I was just trusting people
left and right and then I was getting
burned left and right and it was like oh
god I need to be more of a LA but maybe
maybe that's not a la thing but it's
like a small town boy living in a big
city
yeah yeah I mean cuz that that happens
to people that go to New York that
happens to people that go to like any
major city I think like the mentality is
totally different I feel like it's
having family clothes I don't know I
don't know how my reason is then -
because I have a really bad [ __ ]
meter - and I believe everything people
tell me too though like there's also
there's also the city boys like people
who are like born raised in South
Detroit yeah I think where's this point
going that's why I thought I don't know
I just think I think you shouldn't stop
believin
anyway third point people who feel
lonely have social skills that are no
better or worse than average because a
lot of people assume that lonely people
have really bad social skills
number four is winter is no lonelier
than any other time of the year hmm
people who feel lonely will feel lonely
no matter what time of the year is I
disagree so winters not lonely years
epic according to the survey like this
is the results that they found yeah
people that have depression and feel
lonely are gonna feel that way no matter
what I'm saying like usually the
misconception is that it's worse around
the holidays then why are there more
suicides around the holidays we're
talking about the UK here it's always
winter difference that there there are
people that get the summertime sadness
that's what they wrote in here too that
a lot of them mainly had you know
summertime or it would be Christmas too
but it's just the fact that is not it
doesn't spike up during Christmas - man
I you guys always have that one
particular friend that they always say
that they're happy being single but any
chance that they get they always have to
talk about how they're single it's
better I come home and there's no one
there and I really like it leave all the
money yeah that's true cuz my secret
friends that are single you see them
living the life but they don't talk
about it yeah they just they're too busy
enjoying it sometimes just want to put
my hand on her shoulder be like dude
just [ __ ] die reminds me of that
Nacho Libre scene where he's like by
myself it makes me want to grab them by
the shoulder like Robin Williams and
[ __ ] Good Will Hunting just single
guys and on the big it's not your fault
shut up it's not your fault it's not
your fault
I get that oh alright last one here is
people who often feel lonely have higher
levels of empathy than everyone else
that kind of makes sense because they
understand people's physical pain and
emotional when you're two I think when
you're too empathetic to you are
sensitive toward humans and and what
they're going through or whatever and
it's overwhelming I think that's what
kind of separates super social and not
too social I don't know yeah oh that's
right you have to be really particular
about who you hang around with because
you don't want that [ __ ] energy Oh
sometimes do you think it's lonely so
you think um when you see someone eating
alone do you think that's sad no because
I do it all the food court
it's a bar where the games were all
playing this lady is drinking alone
watching the game and you'd like she's
her before us that's really sad
she's just alone look that's not sad
what if she's enjoying her time outside
of the house it's to say watching yeah
you know watching the most social sport
ever football yeah but but in a bar
alone with a beer and pharmacies you're
supposed to watch your team play I don't
know what if she has a house full of
five kids that are allowed as [ __ ] and
then she wants to just [ __ ] out like
thank you I would defend it as I do this
not not drink alone in a bar but I'll
watch sports alone because again the
privacy of your home bill right I'll go
to a restaurant now just like when I
lived alone I didn't have cable
so I would go across the street to the
Barger in the Packers games and I would
watch and drink along was yeah but
you're a [ __ ] hot chick dude will
come up to you all the times of matter
yeah you have to
yeah it's Sunday Saturday football
you're you're a self-described the
lonely depressed person though no but I
feel doing what I feel more lonely and a
crowd full of people like that are
partying like if I'm at a party a house
brother because you feel left out yeah
and I feel like I don't know any of
these people I'm supposed to talk and I
don't you know I'm supposed to talk but
then if I'm by myself I'm having a blast
like if I'm like eating and by myself
I [ __ ] love being alone not your
fault it's not your fault beyond like
hikes and stuff
[Music]